let me begin thanking you for for this
opportunity to speak today in the bully
it's my first time that had the
opportunity to to be in the Greek
parliament and honored and happy about
this and I will introduce a few remarks
on our strategy for a greener and fairer
economy also taking a few of the issues
that was developed by our chair let me
also thank Minister stai chorus for
being here to attend this meeting be
assured that I intend to engage as
closely as possible with national
parliamentarians during my mandate and
where better to start and in Athens the
cradle of European democracy and also in
a particular day because we are coming
yesterday from some decisions in the
European Commission that are strictly
linked what with the argument we are
discussing this morning I know very well
that increased social and economic
effects of the last prices are still
keenly felt in the country but after so
many difficulties for the Greek people
and so many efforts to get the country
back on track I'm very pleased that
economic conditions are now clearly
improving growth in two
thousand nineteen his Lytle who have
significantly outperformed the euro-area
average which unfortunately is lowered
unemployment has dropped below seventeen
percent which is still very high but
continues to fall capital's controls
have been fully lift and confidence it's
his highest level since 2007 these good
news has started to pass through the
Greek sovereign ratings bringing the
return to investment great ever closer
the government's ambitious pro-growth
agenda has fostered this positive
sentiment and paved the way for last
December's Eurogroup agreement to
release 770 million euros of debt
measures based on a favor will forth
enhanced surveillance report as you know
the fifth report has just been finished
and will be presented at the end of this
month
in short Greece has come a long way and
is now in a much stronger position to
face the challenges ahead
last week Europe lived a sad day as Brad
seed finally became a reality happily
the threat of grexit no longer casts its
shadow over Greece and the euro
my message to you is that the European
Commission will be by your side as
Greece completes its journey back to
normality and moves in step with the
rest of your euro area to face the new
challenges ahead of us our challenges
with clouds on the horizons some link to
trade tensions and others to lower
global growth Europe needs to raise its
game we need to be able to develop a
more attractive investment environment
we need to create new economic
opportunities and quality jobs
especially for young people Europe faces
a combination of short-term and
longer-term challenges which are already
knocking our door climate change is an
increasingly dramatic reality the
digital transition is changing the way
we live and work the prospect of low for
longer growth is a real one low growth
low investments low inflation against
the background of trade disputes and
aging population increasing inequalities
among our citizens and global worry in
spite of all efforts make by the
European Central Bank core inflation
remains subdued inequality is on the
rise with the richest 1% of the
population accumulating more and more
wealth so the challenge of making our
economy is more productive more
sustainable and more inclusive is darker
than ever before a coherent strategy
beyond monetary policy which is
increasingly constrained a coherent
strategy is therefore needed to avert
the perspective of the slow growth and
unequal economy to steer the economy
towards sustainable growth and jobs we
will need to deploy the full set of
policy tool available to us let me
mention three key priorities first
making a success
of the climate's transition this is the
defining task of our times and the
number one priority for the Commission I
think it's very significant that the
European Commission has this profile and
has the ambition to lead the global
challenge of climate transition by the
way who who else could lead this
challenge of the climate transition if
not Europe global warming the depletion
of natural resources and continued
biodiversity loss together with
increasing forest fires floods and other
natural disasters threaten both lives
and livelihoods the European Green Deal
is our ambitious response to this
challenge and our roadmap to achieving
climate neutrality by 2050 a an
ambitious target as well as being an
environment necessity this is also a
tremendous economic opportunity for
Europe and for Greece I think the
European Green Deal provides a framework
for us to deliver the transformative
change we need across all sectors many
of them will be implemented in the
Commission's first year in office they
are linked in the European Green Deal
investment plan which I presented last
month which aims as should the chair
remind us to mobilize at least 1
trillion of sustainable investments over
the next decade and which also has a
mechanism to face the social the
fickle tease contradictions and
consequences of the climate transition
this is the so called just transition
fund that should be used in areas where
the transition is more necessary because
of the high level of emissions and could
create more serious social consequences
and there are regions in your country
that are especially interested and
affected by this issue
let me also briefly mention specific
initiatives I will be working on in the
coming year as part of our efforts to
deliver the climate transition in a fair
manner while protecting European
interest first we will be reviewing our
energy taxation framework which is 17
years old and no longer fit for purpose
with its privileged treatment of
outright exemptions for certain types of
fuel or certain modes of transport
second we will be designing a cardboard
border adjustment mechanism always
complicate definitions and acronyms and
in new carbon borders adjustment
mechanism to ensure that progressing
towards carbon neutrality in the EU does
not lead to industrial jobs and
investment moving beyond our borders to
countries that do not share a level of
ambition clearly this mechanism will
have to be designed in a way that it is
compatible with WTO rules second
challenge adapting our economic
governance to the new reality to the new
contest
yesterday I presented the Commission's
review of our economic governance
framework marking the start of five
months
of public debate with Member States
government's Parliament's and that's you
the European Parliament the European
Central Bank at an institution
stakeholders academia this would be the
public consultation on our governance
framework I really hope that this will
be a constructive and result oriented
discussion because we need the result
oriented discussion we are not
discussing for history or for making a
think-tank meeting looking back over the
past few years it is fair to say that
our rules helped to reduce deficits 24
countries where in excess is definite
procedures in 2011 none is today and
have improved the coordination of our
fiscal policies we have now a common
timing and common targets in our fiscal
policies even with if we maintain fiscal
policy in the power of national
governments and Parliament we have had
mixed result with the reduction of debt
overall public debt has been reduced to
around 86 percent of GDP in the euro
area and 79 percent of GDP in EU in
general if we consider other global
players we see that the US has that of
115 and Japan 237 percent
but our reduction was not a uniform
reduction and besides Greece also in a
number of the
trees that remain around of above 100%
of GDP this is why about that time
saying that we had mix at result
declining public debt but with
differences among member states I would
say the complexity of our rules is also
a mixed result in the sense that our
rules have become more intelligent over
the years because complexity is
frequently intelligence it allows
flexibility it allows to take political
decisions when needed but at the price
of becoming more complex which has been
bad for ownership of decisions by member
state as well as making it more
difficult to explain those decisions to
our citizens and then there are some
clear shortcomings in this economic
governance for sure we were not able to
have an anti cyclical set of rules and
we were not able to increase the rate of
public investment which has in fact
decreased in the last 20 years and in
the last 10 years
now we are in very different times from
when these rules the six-pack and the
2-pack were delivered 10 years ago we
were in a deep crisis then we had
several years of recovery or even a
robust expansion in our economy now as I
mentioned already we are in a phase of
low growth which risks becoming
protracted so deep crisis strong or
substantial grow
for several years and now low-growth
with the risk of low for long so we need
to ensure we preserve stability to be
sure now nobody is discussing the
fundamental pillars of our stability but
equally we need to make sure we can
mobilize the immense investments
required to tackle climate change and
transition to the fusion we have put on
the table a series of questions in this
review of our economic governance which
include how to better ensure sustainable
public finance and tackle macroeconomic
imbalances how to avoid procyclical
policies how to support growth friendly
public finances and the incentivize
reforms and investment how to make the
framework simpler and more transparent
how to make the framework more focused
on gross errors in this discussion we
will need both ambition and an
extraordinary effort to bridge
differences and work constructively for
meaningful improvements making an effort
to have a common vision this is not a
technical exercise this is about jobs
well-being and protection of our
communities so I count in your active
engagement the Parliament and the
government of Greece in this public
debate my third and last point the
completing of the economic and monetary
union we need to make decisis progress
during this mandate in completing the
economic and monetary union this is a
ploy a priority for the euro area to
become the engine of
of prosperity and stability I want to be
clear we need to go further than what
has been agreed so far we collectively
need to cross those red lines that have
generated a stalemate because why we are
now in a statement in completing the
economic and monetary union so I urge
also you to continue supporting the
Commission's push for deeper integration
also if we know that some of the
Commission proposals were not capable to
fly in the last couple of years because
of different position among member
states but completely the financial
union is a prerequisite for ensuring
stability of the euro area and spurring
private investment on the scale needed
to address the medium-term challenges
including the green transition member
states even if we will facilitate
through the rules will not be able
member state to generate sufficient
funds on their own the banking and
capital markets Union are also necessary
to reduce the fragmentation of banking
and capital markets increase private
risk sharing and thus bolster investor
confidence in the euro area so
vulnerable members the economic crisis
has undermined trusts among member
states this is the fact with a sharp
divide between that and creditor
countries to move forward we have to
overcome this divide we need to rebuild
confidence and to do so a diplomatic
effort will not be enough confidence
must be built up around the common
vision and project this is the
opportunity offered to us by the
challenge of the climate transition
which will be the defining mission of
the next five years and which I urge you
to actively support thank you fre stop
[Applause]